there are many people in your industry
who talk a good game they talk about
relationships
but let's be honest it's [ __ ] they
just want to make the transaction and
move on
and uh they pretend that they care and
they pretend
it's you know that they care about their
relationship when the reality is
it's one and done and on to the next and
that's what happened to me
i i had a mortgage broker uh he sold me
a mortgage he was recommended to me
that's how most of us meet somebody you
know uh
and he was very nice and charming and
was there with me and then my my
my sale went through and he called me up
to congratulate me
and i was feeling all warm and fuzzy
towards him and then
as soon as he congratulated me said and
if you could recommend me to anybody
else i'd be really grateful
like and he wasn't calling to
congratulate me
he was calling to remind me to put in a
good word for him somewhere else
like if he actually cared about me and
my house then he would have just called
me really excited that i got my house
and if he wanted something from me he
would have waited a wee a week or two
to ask the favor but the gu it became
abundantly clear to me i'm in the human
behavior business
yes he never called me because he cared
about me
and by the way i will never ever
recommend him
because it was never i realized that i
was just a number on a spreadsheet
and so if you actually care about
building relationships then actually
build relationships
you know i remember when i was starting
out my career i had a young ma
a little marketing consultancy and i
came from an industry that pretended
that they were good at everything the
marketing world like literally they
pretended they were good at everything
whether they were or weren't and when i
went off by myself
it was important to me to be honest and
clients would come and talk to me and
say
we want to hire you to do all these
things and i'd say i'll do that one i'm
really good at that
pretty good at that i like doing that
that i'm mediocre on
that i suck at i highly recommend you
hire another company to do that and i'm
happy to
partner with them and it made them want
to do business with me more
because you said no because i told them
what i was good at what i was bad at
where i was super honest yeah
and we've all had that experience where
you want to hire somebody and they go
you should let me introduce you to
something it happened to me recently
yeah
i wanted a is it like something silly
yeah you know i needed wallpaper
yeah i he highly recommended i called
him up he came he gave me a quote
he's like you know what i'm not the best
at this thing and he gave me the number
of somebody else yeah now all i want to
do is work with him again and i keep
giving out his phone number
to other people even though i actually
never did work with him
because what builds a relationship is an
honest broker
honesty is such a hard thing to get
especially in a transaction business
especially in a commodity business
because it is just volume in numbers
yeah and that when you actually find an
honest one
all you want to do is help them build
their book of business even though you
may never do business with them and
that's what a lot of finite minded
folks in your business don't get yeah
which is you may never sell me a
mortgage but i'll become your biggest
[Music]
champion
you